[Music]
great leaders are committed to
developing other people as leaders which
often means putting them in positions
where they might fail encouraging them
to step outside their comfort zone and
helping them learn from setbacks and
mistakes as opposed to punishing them
for setbacks and mistakes immediately
great leaders also really internalize
the responsibility to embody the culture
and to walk the talk it's a truism in
organizational life that the you know
the sort of the the values plaque you
know the principles that we put up on
the wall is kind of BS and and I think
that's because in a lot of circumstances
people see a big gap between you know
the the plaque on the wall and the
leaders actual behavior they are finely
attuned to moments where the leader is
not acting in alignment with those
principles and so I think great
leadership really means committing to
understanding those principles
internalizing them and and being very
deliberate about following through on
them especially when they don't align
with what the leader believes to be
their self-interest you know if a leader
is going to you know follow the values
on the plaque on the wall
only when it's personally expedient I'd
say that creates a very toxic
environment in which people realize you
know those values in the wall are not
going to be followed they're not ones
that we need to to listen to either
a theme that comes up a lot in my
practice is that leaders occupy a
particularly important symbolic role and
I think this is often neglected in
contemporary organizational life we tend
to think of leaders as you know decision
makers and we think of leaders a very
strategic sense they're going to
determine the course of the organization
and they're going to set strategy and
they're going to allocate resources
that's all true it's also very cognitive
and I think what that leaves out is the
emotional impact that a leader has as
the symbolic leader of the tribe the
symbolic dimension of organizational
life is one that comes up quite a lot in
my practice people join organizations
and feel committed to organizations to a
certain extent because of the feeling of
community that they enjoy among their
colleagues and the commitment that they
feel from the leader to sort of invest
in the health and development to growth
of that community doesn't mean that a
leader is obligated to solve for those
factors but recognizing their leader
bears a unique responsibility to help
that community feel a sense of
collective identity and and growth
great leaders are also able to make a
distinction between leading and doing
many of the people I work with have a a
technical background either as coders or
developers as investors or financial
analysts and they've achieved third
leadership position by virtue of their
technical prowess and that is often very
useful in the early stages of a
company's development because other
people are looking to leader for that
kind of technical expertise and yet if a
leader remains stuck in the process of
doing if they are you know essentially
the doer in chief that if they're if
their leadership rests on their ability
to be the most you know the most
effective you know person at that
particular technical discipline or you
know the proverbial smartest person in
the room
then they're gonna cap the
organization's of ability to grow they
will inhibit the organization's capacity
to scale so you know a transitional
phase that I help a lot of leaders
navigate through is this period of being
the the most technically adept person in
a given discipline to a phase in which
they're actually adding value not on the
basis of their technical expertise
because they're hiring people who have
deeper expertise in their particular
discipline and so the leader is not
adding value by telling that technical
expert how to do their job or by you
know even worse kind of shouldering that
person out of the way and in doing their
job for them but by bringing a group of
technically adept people together and
helping them operate as a team
ultimately that distinction between
weeding and doing is how the leader
truly helps an organization scale
[Music]
you
[Music]
you